so good to see you all Amy
why did we wait 15 years
for this sequel I know like there are
people that could watch the first movie
every day for 15 years yeah absolutely
but what was it that took this long to
get this story you know I believe in
fate and I think we were waiting for
Gabby to be ready and Maya to be ready
and for the cast to be free and the
story to be right and the timing to be
right in the world where we were ready
for Giselle again and I really feel like
I believe in in sort of the Serendipity
of this moment for the movie to come out
yeah that's fantastic yeah so many Heavy
Hitters in this cast and Gabby if I can
say you absolutely knock it out of the
park thank you so much she does isn't
she fantastic so good I want to ask you
what was it like
well what was it like for you Gabby when
you stepped onto set with all of these
people I remember seeing your when Adam
and Amy told you that you got the role
and just how exciting that was to see so
what was it like for you when you
actually stepped on there oh my God this
was my favorite Enchanted was one of my
favorite movies growing up literally my
favorite so I felt like I had this
connection to these characters and these
people would obviously I didn't know so
when I was stepping into this world it
was like oh my gosh here I am but also
it was just embraced with like the most
Open Arms everyone was so kind and wise
and I just learned
so so much from my cast mates and it's
just surreal you know
really lucky she was a Phenom because we
were looking for such a special package
and she just had it all I mean she can
sing she can dance she can act and she
looked bizarrely like Morgan and we just
were like are we even like this is such
a magic moment right now to get to cast
Morgan with Gabby it was magic for all
of us yeah and Maya to Amy's earlier
point about like
um it being serendipitous that everyone
is available for this movie at this time
you fall into this role so perfectly
well I love this evil queen thing when
you when you and Amy have your big face
off your Magical Musical face off what
was the first thing you guys said to
each other before you started rolling
that day
see on the Dance Floor kid
I don't remember I just couldn't I was
like oh my gosh you look so amazing I
love your feathers I
was just gosh yeah yeah we're just sort
of I mean from the beginning geeked out
about the whole thing anyway and then
before I arrived Amy got to do a lot of
her stuff which really helped me because
I understood you know we we did some
carriageography separately we ride off
in our carriages separately so I got to
see sort of what she was doing like okay
it's gonna be this level like we got it
and then I I felt like I was training
for a marathon and then I finally got
there and I was like this is the day
yeah we're doing it today and we did it
straight for 10 hours oh we did for real
all day all day baby just in that Cafe
just that part yeah but it was it was
like what we what we trained for and it
was it felt so good and so gratifying
because it was the culmination of all of
the hard work and there were a couple
times
I gotta put the corset back on like I
got you know you gotta take it off
sometimes to use the bathroom or like
can I sit down you know things like that
but you like gotta get back up gotta get
in that course I gotta get back on get
back in the ring yeah I figured out how
to lay down in the corset yeah there was
a lot more she ended up just laying down
the floor at a certain point reading her
books it's true forget the superheroes
it's all about those queen and princess
dresses that's where it's really at
well thank you so much for your time I'm
very very excited for people to see this
great job congratulations thank you